when you see the word regions right well
we're we're real functions of the minute
okay what it really implies is
inequalities right regions come from
inequalities okay we've actually been
dealing with this for quite some time
but in most simple terms so example and
draw this with me if I say X is greater
than 3 this is all about taking these
these functions relations and so on
taking them algebraically and
representing their visually region is a
visual thing it's like it's literally a
drawing okay now we can draw this we can
draw this inequality how would we do it
on a line very good right you draw a
line like so and you say okay well for
all the values like 3 & 3 foot 1 & 4 & 5
& 100 and so on all of those satisfy
this inequality right so fine chug zero
in today because you always have to give
one two three yes three and except for
three itself any value over here
most satisfy this inequality right so
what I've got here is a diagrammatic
representation of what I have written
algebraic okay that's very important to
mention that when you are X is greater
than three right
that's a region and its boundary its
boundaries x equals three that
particular point is the boundary
okay now the reason why a number line is
exactly right is the most appropriate
way to demonstrate this is because a
number line is one dimensional one
dimensional and I have one variable here
right one unknown one thing that can
change one variable so then what would
happen if I wanted to have not one
variable but two very real functions on
the Cartesian plane are we so let's draw
a car did you play if I gave you just
like I'd given you here an inequality if
I gave you an inequality that had two
variables in it I guess because we're on
the Cartesian plane we would call them
X&Y but they really could be anything we
like if I gave you an inequality with
XYZ then it would take the Cartesian
plane to draw it because now we have two
dimensions rather than just this one
okay now before I actually give you a
question let me just come back to this
because we've been dealing with this
long enough that we know this is the
solution that we can literally even when
you read this because it's quite simple
you can see it in your mind you're
familiar with this okay but there are
actually two methods method 1 method 2
for solving this inequality and working
out what to draw okay you don't need
both methods at the moment because
you're so familiar with this but as we
transition to the regions which is a bit
trickier you're gonna need to employ
both in different measures so here are
the two methods right method one which
is a better method and it's the way to
almost certainly you might about this is
to think directionally right so as soon
as you see X is greater than three
you're like oh Graner then that's to the
right you don't even have to think like
that that that process you know as soon
as I froze got example when I write this
you don't have to think to picture that
in your mind it's just there in fact
it's hard to not have it in your mind
right and in the same way when you see X
is greater than thing a Direction pops
into your head okay I'm gone that way
that's good that's actually it's method
one because it's the best method and
it's what I'm going to encourage you
towards here but it becomes a bit more
difficult when we have a look at two
dimensions this is another way of doing
it that it works with our original
question which is to test values okay so
you remember I said 4x is greater than 3
x equals 3 is the boundary okay so let
me just come back to where I had my
number line right imagine you know this
didn't come so obviously 2 then you're
like oh it's to the right you've got 0 1
2 okay there's my boundary I know that's
my boundary now every boundary point
divides up the number line into two
there's one side and then there's the
other side okay so all we need to do to
work out is that this side or that side
is to test a value right for instance
pick one like say x equals 0 x equals 0
that's here okay now I can think about
this and I could say all right on that
inequality the left hand side if I'm
testing x equals 0 but left hand side
will be 0
the right hand side is just the constant
is just 3 so is it true what is the
relationship between the left hand side
and the right hand side is it true that
the left hand side is greater and the
answer is no is not true okay
so therefore for x equals 0 this
inequality is not satisfied so I'm not
on this side clearly I have nowhere else
to go I must be on this side and
obviously if I test another matter that
x equals 4 I would find oh cool it does
satisfy this equality the left hand side
would be grand the right hand side and
ahead I go okay so I have these two
approaches I can think about all right
this thing means go this way or that way
so if you're familiar which way it means
then you can just draw the arrow
alternatively if that doesn't come to
you straight away you just pick a number
pick a number on either side of your
boundary and then just go for it so
let's now apply that to regions he's our
example y is greater than
X plus 1 Y is greater than X plus 1 hmm
okay now the first thing we want to say
is just like I had before when you've
got greater than that's that's a whole
bunch of different values right they
defined they lined off by our boundary
right and the boundaries you take me in
equality and you make an equal sign
let's say y equals x plus 1 is the
boundary okay now just like in a number
line diagram right when you have the
boundary and you don't want to include
it we have a hollow circle and if you do
want to include it you have a fill or
closed circle okay this is exactly the
same thing happening with these
boundaries have a look at the inequality
that I gave you is the boundary included
or not
it is not it's not inclusive doesn't
have that line there so the
corresponding thing for a whole is
circle for 2d regions rather than a
whole bunch of polar circles it's a
dotted line okay so why because x1 when
I draw this thing there is y equals x
plus 1 and as usual you label because we
want to know what these things are and
soon enough we're going to have quite a
few of them flying around so I have some
intercepts here curious 1 so that's all
fine okay now we have two methods here
we can think they're actually or we can
test values ok
now thinking directionally here is a
little less straightforward so I'm
actually going to show you the testing
boundaries because even though it's
quite crude isn't it slow in some ways
it's easy to see it's easy to convince
yourself that it's true now hang up
because we're only on one dimension you
just pick x equals this or x equals that
but I'm on the Cartesian plane here
right so you can't just pick an x value
it has to have a corresponding Y value
right so you have a look what might be a
nice easy point to test on our Cartesian
plan it's gotta be on one side amenities
how about the origin right if the origin
isn't on the boundary right and
frequently unfortunately the origin is
on the boundary and then it's not it's
not helpful because once you try the
boundary you know it's not included okay
but if the boundary doesn't pass through
the origin you should always use it it's
just so easy so let's have a go this
left hand side I'm testing out zero zero
I actually would say that test okay the
left hand side is just Y which is zero
the right hand side is zero plus one
it's just one I can't say is the
inequality true or not left hand side is
it greater than the right hand side and
- no it's not right so therefore zero
zero is not in the region that I'm after
it's not because I just failed the test
okay so now that means it must be the
other side it's not on this side it must
be on this side that's it that's all you
have to do I'm going to shade up here
you'll be able to do this much better
with pencil but I don't have what can't
use a pencil to the earth that's it okay
yes
okay right so this was this was the
method of testing values okay a better
way which I'm going to try and encourage
you towards but it's not as it's not as
straightforward as this and not as easy
convinced is to think about it in terms
of directions okay so now let's think
about this
why is greater than something okay why
is greater than something now for
instance if I gave you like a number if
I said like if I said Y is greater than
seven okay we know Y is greater than
seven means above means up right so you
can think in terms of the directions
wise and it was less than seven you say
it's born okay in exactly the same way
if I have Y is greater than X plus one
right what that core supposed to is
above y equals x plus one that's the
boundary right when you've got Y is the
subject you can read it as it's
everything it for above is that boundary
okay that make sense
he's my boundary and I'm going above
does that make sense okay now that's not
the only way to think about it by the
way like we used to think in terms of
left to right you can do that as well
watch this I can think in terms of up
and down because Y is the subject and Y
is a vertical thing okay but if I change
this inequality right so that X is the
subject instead then I will be able to
say it's left or right okay so for
instance I'm going to say let's actually
do this okay let's let's cut that one
over to that side it's alright
and I want X is the subject so I'm going
to say X is less than Y minus one now
just keep in mind right I've rearranged
things but the boundary hasn't changed
has it right I've just moved things back
and forth
now that X is the subject I less then
less than when you told me greater than
its to the right so if X is less than it
means to the left of y equals x plus one
which sure enough there's your line and
I'm going to the left does that make
sense
okay so this method is better this
method is better you can see what's
going on you can understand me you can
interpret you like oh I'm gonna be that
way I'm gonna be that way
okay however what's great about this is
it's like look you can't argue with it
right like here here's some times you
haven't been a doubt also it's not
always so straightforward to make X the
subject will make why this subject
sometimes you'll get something messy and
then in terms of directions you like mmm
don't we try to go here in which case
just fall back on this it works it's
simple it's relatively efficient in the
kitchen answer